[Musique]
un moment historique ce matin dans
l'hémicycle du département en présence
de françoise et pierre vergès une
convention a été signée
les archives personnelles de paul vergès
ont été données aux archives
départementales de la réunion
exceptionnelle de paul et laurence
vergès où nous pouvons retrouver
l'histoire de la réunion avec des
documents exceptionnels
toute l'histoire passée de la
décolonisation au statut de département
mais également de tous les combats qui
ont été menées c'est la vie d'un homme
et à travers la vie de cet homme je
crois que c'est aussi l'histoire de la
réunion que nous allons revisiter un
fonds qui désormais appartient à tous
les réunionnais pour françoise et pierre
vergès c'est à la nouvelle génération de
s'emparer de ces documents historiques
donc c'est respecter déjà la volonté
évidemment de notre peur et de mes deux
évidemment d'insérer et d'intégrer les
papiers de notre mère au niveau
économique fixe étapes sont
extraordinaires il ya des photos
absolument inédite depuis les années 45
jusqu'aux années 2000 il ya des films
iliad est vraiment je veux dire c'est
une ouverture extraordinaire pas
seulement pour les chercheurs mais pour
des artistes par des cinéastes pour des
personnes qui veulent faire des
documentaires
c'est elle est enfin façon de tout
garder qui les permet aux
duy de pouvoir restituer au public aux
chercheurs ont des argiles inestimable
deux décennies d'une vie rêvée les
intenses
à la suite de cette signature de
convention les élus du département se
sont penchés sur divers rapports en
séance plénière parmi ceux ci la
désignation de la collectivité pour
participer à une expérimentation de
certification des comptes publics
c'est une très bonne chose parce que le
fait d'avoir des comptes certifiés cela
des mots d'enfants en toute transparence
que notre collectivité bien cher et
c'est aussi je dirais dans un moment où
toutes les collectivités les communes
les départements les régions sont
confrontés à des baisses de dotations de
l'état
nous nous avons perdu faut-il le
rappeler près de 30 millions d'euros
depuis trois ans les tanzaniens 30
millions d'euros malgré tout cela nous
avons réussi à maintenir un équilibre et
la cour des comptes nous accepte dans le
champ de l'expérimentation
c'est la preuve que nous encouragent à
maintenir nos efforts de bonne gestion
de la collectivité
autres dossiers à l'ordre du jour l'aide
accordée par la collectivité à la
filière agricole notamment sur deux
secteurs qui doivent faire face à une
concurrence acharnée issues de
l'importation
pour exemple l'aïe qui ne couvre que 4 %
des besoins du marché réunionnais qui
est confronté à 1690 tonnes d'ail
importé de la zone océan indien
c'est le 7e tour mais les dalles en
pierre
l'absurdité de l'emmener plus mieux des
conduites en soi sans la vie sauve à
jour et une séance qui a aussi permis
d'acter la revalorisation de l'indemnité
journalière versée aux assistants
familiaux une revalorisation qui a pris
effet au 1er janvier 2017
[Musique]